>>Male Presenter: Jeff Potter is one of us.
He's a geek. He studied Computer Science at
Brown, done his time in a cube at a start-up.
He's organized BarCamp, a Boston-based technology
unconference, for and by attendees. And today,
we've asked him to come talk about his other
geek hobby, food.
Jeff's book, "Cooking For Geeks," which some
of you might have found on your chairs, sprung
from his passion for food. With no formal
culinary training, Jeff wrote a book about
food. It's not really a cookbook. It's got
a whole chapter on food-borne illness--
[laughter]
that he's conveniently broken into two sections,
parasites and bacteria. But you can't really
classify it like that.
Similarly, it's not really one of these detailed
recipe porn books where they show you the
recipe and then they have beautiful pictures
'cause he dug a bit and devoted a number of
pages on Twitter recipes and publishing in
a couple of hundred characters a recipes.
So, it's really a book about food that appeals
to people who like to overanalyze, kinda like
us. All right. I'm happy someone's written
a book about food for people like me. I'm
hoping today he'll answer my question about
why we call them "cookies" and not "bakies,"
when clearly they should be called bakies.
And--
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: AT&T burn.
>>Male Presenter: And with great pleasure,
I'd like to introduce Jeff Potter.
>>Jeff Potter: Thank you.
[applause]
Thanks for the great kind words. I hope I
live up to the hype. And of course, there's
nothing better for a geek than a Venn diagram.
So, I get asked a lot, "What's a geek?"
And I'm like, "This is the answer to what
a geek is." Note the [inaudible] bit is not
included in the set of the things that make
a geek up. And for me, that's like really
important to people who invariably think pocket
protectors and all this other stuff. But it's
not what it's about.
For me it's really about curiosity. And as
Jeremy was saying, for me, whether it's in
front of a computer or in the kitchen, it's
really the curiosity about how things work
that gets me excited. And so, when it comes
to cooking, it's exactly the same thing. How
does this thing that we do in the kitchen,
how does it actually work?
Why do we do the things we do the way we do
them? And once you know those things, what
can you do that's fun, new, interesting, or
just plain delicious? Continuing the theme
of Venn diagrams, figuring that it's Google,
I figured the Google Venn diagram generator
was appropriate.
You know, pointing at things like Windows
and Apple. You can see there's some interesting
traits like, I guess everyone knows why Apple
is so popular because people don't seem to
search for it. "Why is Windows so popular?"
comes up a lot. Hey. Here's another one which
is a little more interesting.
It has chefs versus geeks versus bakers. Geeks
clearly don't wear white. I don't quite get
the "like bacon" bit. I would think it would
be under "cooks" as well, but you know. Then
the last one: Science, cooking, and food.
And the interesting thing for me is all three
of these things are important.
And I thought it was actually nice to see
that come up. So, a bit about science. And
it's always fun to talk about science in the
context of dead white dudes. So, I present
to you three dead white dudes: Aristotle,
Newton, and Einstein. And the thing that these
three guys all have in common is they all
came up with models of gravity.
And in science, models are really, really
important. Aristotle's model was really, really
simple. He basically sent things to fall at
a rational place. So, the drop that falls,
I don't know why it didn't fall in my mouth,
but it's a really simple model and it's not
very good.
In the 1800s, we start getting better models.
Galileo came up with something that describes
basic high school physics for gravity. It's
still taught in high school today. It's pretty
good as a model goes. But it's not actually
perfect. It doesn't actually describe Mercury's
orbit around the sun, rather famously.
And you actually can't describe that with
that law. You have to get an even better model,
something that Einstein came up with, the
Theory of Relativity. And that actually accounts
for Mercury's orbit around the sun. The point
here is that with better models, you get better
predictions.
And it's true in all sciences and it's true
in the kitchen. So, let's actually talk about
a model of cooks, types of cooks. Right now,
your model of types of cooks is probably pretty
simple. But how many types of cooks are there?
So that's two types. People who like to cook
things and people who like to bake things.
But it's actually a very simple model. It's
Ancient Greece territory in terms of like,
"Yeah, this sounds good." But it doesn't actually
really describe what's going on in the kitchen
that well. So, the researcher down at Cornell
got some data, looked at thousands of cooks,
home cooks, and asked them lots of questions
and did a factor analysis.
And he came up with this five-factor model
that describes five different types of cooks
that describe most types of cooks. And luckily,
he came up with a quiz for it. So, here's
a quiz. This is a really simple quiz. The
way we do this is just to keep track of what
letter you answer most often.
And whatever that letter is in the end, that's
your type. It only accounts for about 85 to
90% of the population. And given the people
in this room, I have my guesses about how
this is gonna go.
[laughter]
I will say that under normal populations,
there's a roughly 20% split between all five
types. So, keep that in mind when you go through
this. First question: When I cook a meal,
I typically dot dot dot.
If anyone needs me to read these off, holler.
But if you can see them great.
[pause]
Everybody good? Should I go to the next one?
OK. Some of my favorite ingredients are. That
thing from the kitchen around the corner.
They did the right cookies. Anyone have Dayquil
for me?
Unusual tea. It's not unusual to you because
of cultural things, then it’s not an unusual
ingredient. Shall I go to the next one? Howdy.
In my free time I like to. OK, I know you
guys are like, "What free time?"
[laughter]
Next one? My favorite things to cook are.
Jeremy, are you A on this?
>>Male Presenter: Mmm.
>>Jeff Potter: Looked good.
>>Male Presenter: Thank you.
>>Jeff Potter: Your recipe. Delicious.
[pause]
Are we good? OK. And the last one. Other people
describe me as. And F is a joke. I put that
in there in a previous talk. Don't actually
answer F. If won't do us any good.
[laughter]
>>Male Audience Member #1: What about none
of the above?
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: This only fits 90% of the population
plus or minus delta. So, I'm curious to see
a show of hands. Who here said "A"? So it’s
like, let's see, five or six? "B"? Only five
or six. "C"? Probably about seven. OK, "D"?
Yeah, about 40&, like half the room. "E"?
Two. OK. That's cool. So here's what these
things mean.
The researcher who did this was Dr.Brian Munson
down at Cornell and he basically looked at
types of cooks. There's giving types of cooks,
so people can basically, they basically wanted
to express their affection through baking.
So they should all show up at work with a
box full of gingerbread cookies.
And what they're really saying is "hey, I
love you guys." Then you go, "Thanks. That's
really cool. I like them." Thanks, Jeremy.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: I love you guys.
>>Jeff Potter: It's like next time someone
shows up with a plate of brownies, that's
where it's coming from. Healthy. This is somebody
who'll do it for steamed veggies, brown rice,
fish, chicken.
To them food is really about nutritional value,
taking care of the body. Methodical. This
is something you can give them a recipe and
they will nail it perfectly. It'll come out
exactly like a recipe says, but if they're
missing like one ingredient, like, they don't
know what to do.
And Innovative. This is the type of person
who basically like maybe reads a couple recipes,
looks at some TV shows, like walks into the
kitchen and throws stuff into a pan and it
comes out. He doesn't have a good time doing
it. And for them this is kind of like, "Hey.
I'm just goofing off, playing and seeing what
might happen."
And that's really how I like to cook. And
then finally, this Competitor type. This is
somebody who like, for them cooking is almost
an act of expressing who they are as a personality.
Grilling, things that are a little bit chest-thumping
type things. That make sense? It's totally
cool.
But for them it's as much about that act of
cooking and doing that in a competitive realm.
So, that all said, we started with a really
simple model. It's like there's two types
of cooks. But here's a better model. And once
you have a better model, you can start making
better predictions.
So, you can imagine a couple, or maybe somebody
who is really health-driven married to somebody
who is all about expressing affection. So
you know, the girlfriend makes for the boyfriend
a plate of brownies, saying, "Hey, I love
you." And the guys like, "Oh my God, this
isn't fish and veggies. Like Oh, my God, no!"
And you can just see this conflict that comes
up around food. And food is such a thing.
You're laughing about this, but only because
this is a true person?
[laughter]
You have this very pained look. Now with this
better model, you'll understand what's going
on.
[laughter]
She looked at me like, it's really powerful
to have that better model because besides
breaking ground on the front row of an audience,
now we can talk about it. It's not an offense.
So, that whole bit of a model is really, really
powerful. Science, in general, really does
rely on these two thing, theory and data.
And they say this a lot. And a lot of people
go, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. I understand
this in science." But they don't think about
it in the context of the kitchen.
Without your data, your theories are really
no good. You don't know if they're true or
not. Without your theories, well, you just
compile data and you can't predict new data
points that you don't have in your set of
observations. Same thing is true in food.
Here is a model of an equation for knowing
when meat is done being cooked.
[laughter]
I can't read this. I confess I am not a theory
guy. My background is much more on the data
side of things. So, when it comes to the kitchen,
all I think of are data. So, I'll do things
like this. I'll go into a kitchen, take a
lump of chocolate-chip cookie dough, throw
a probe into it, throw it in the oven and
see what happens.
And start recording data. So, what's your
model right now tell you about what happens
to a lump of cookie dough when you throw in
the oven? It cooks. I had someone go " it
turns into a cookie."
[laughter]
[You open the box and put in the dough and
the cookies come out. So if you put an apple
in there, a cookie is just not coming out.]
[laughter]
So, let's look at cookie dough. It's kind
of interesting. So, after I put this probe
in, this little light out here you barely
see. It's actually little probe thermometers,
kitchen, 30 dollar thermometers we've got
at home.
So, around 92 degrees they begin to spread
out and do that thing that you were saying.
That's the temperature which butter begins
to melt. So like, right. OK. This makes some
sense. There's some structure holding this
mass of dough together and that structure
starts to go when butter starts to go.
Isn't that cool? Around 212 degrees, the edge
of the cookie begins to set up. It starts,
again at 212 degrees, an obvious number, the
boiling point of water. And the edge of that
cookie begins to steam up. It's also around
the temperature in which a lot of starches
and things like flour begin to actually like
melt and do their thing as well.
Then at around 310 degrees, the outside of
this cookie begins to turn light brown. Any
guesses what's happening around 310?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Condensation.
>>Jeff Potter: A good guess, but not the right
guess.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Maillard.
>>Jeff Potter: Yes. Who said Maillard? An
extra gingerbread cookie to the man in green.
[laughter]
A Maillard reaction is a breakdown between
proteins and simple sugars. Basically, these
two things break down, form hundreds of new
compounds, some of which are brown, some of
which smell really, really good and we happen
to like.
And if that doesn't do it for you, think about
taking a slice of bread and toasting it. That
toasted smell that you get? That's the Maillard
reaction. And it's really important in cooking
because it brings a whole set of flavors.
So, think about things like brussel sprouts.
Brussel sprouts are universally boiled and
universally hated because the flavors kinda
bland. If you quarter them, throw some olive
oil, some salt on there and put them under
a broiler, you get some nice toasted, rich,
brown outside that help us bring the flavors,
the Maillard reaction.
And that's responsible for a lot of flavor
in foods. And once you start realizing it's
a temperature-dependent reaction, you now
realize right, cooking methods that don't
get that hot won't trigger that reaction.
So, you have to get things that hot to get
that reaction.
When we think about steaming or boiling something,
well, it's gonna bring a loss of flavors.
Then at around 356, 360, somewhere in that
territory, our cookie gets turned even darker
brown. And this is from caramelization, as
you guys were guessing earlier.
And this is pure breakdown of sucrose and
other sugar molecules. This temperature I'm
giving you is for sucrose, specifically. Basically,
it's just the sugar molecule itself is decomposing
and then forming hundreds of compounds again,
some of which are brown, so they smell good.
And it's surprising in hindsight for me, looking
at the book and working on it, how long it
took to understand some really like, basic
"duh" type things. Caramelization has nothing
to do with melting. This happens if sugar
melts right at the same temperature point
that breaks down, decomposes.
Fun fact. Sugar melts at around 367, actually
377, so those after 367. So you can actually
calibrate your oven using sugar, just like
you use on ice cubes. You know how your freezer
is above 32 or below 32. Same thing with your
oven. If you put sugar in your oven at 350,
it shouldn't melt.
If you leave your oven at 375, it should melt.
You can start looking at recipes and say,
"Hey, some recipes call for things being cooked
at 325 or 350. Other recipes at 375." There's
this nice, like break point between these
two sets of temperatures and that is the chemical
reactions that sugar goes through for both
melting and caramelization.
So, here's a nice little visual proof of this.
I just took some sugar dough. It's kind of
hard to see them on the projector. But basically,
I just took some sugar cookie dough and baked
it at different temperatures. And you can
see there's this really nice difference between
that 350 to 375, where it starts to get brown.
And note, on these temperatures, they are
not exact points. These are Maillard reactions.
So like, caramelization picks up the hotter
you go, but it's not really visibly occurring
until around a little bit north of 350. So,
there's a model and then your simple model
of cookie dough to cookie, right?
Next time you're going to make cookies, you
can think about things like, "Hey, do I want
these a deep brown?" In the case of a chocolate
chip cookie. Or, not so brown in cases like
a sugar cookie or an oatmeal cookie. Same
thing is true with meat. Another model for
you. When you cook meat, what happens? Bueller?
Bueller?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Brown, scalded.
>>Jeff Potter: Browned.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: It like burns and
the inside stays cold.
>>Jeff Potter: Do what?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: The outside burns
and the inside stays cold.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: It turns brown
and when it breaks down you get texture.
>>Jeff Potter: Yes. You get textural breakdowns
when a number of the proteins denature. And
specifically, at least in the papers I've
been able to find, it seems like there are
different proteins that are responsible for
this, some of which we happen to like being
denatured when cooked, and some of which we
happen to like being in a native, uncooked
state.
Specifically, the two are myosin and actin.
Different types of meats have different variants
of these proteins when temperatures vary a
little bit. But essentially for a thing like
steak, it looks like right at 122 degrees
one of these proteins, myosin, begins to denature.
And in the process of denaturation, changes
its texture, changes the way it tastes and
the way we perceive it. And we happen to like
that change. And if you look at another protein,
what we call actin, it begins to go somewhere
around 150. And unlike myosin when it denatures,
it changes its texture and gets tough and
dry and not so delicious.
If you look at things like medium-rare steak,
it's at this temperature point, 135, 140,
where you basically mean one of those proteins
is cooked and another one uncooked. So suddenly,
it's like, "Oh, right." This thing is about
the particular reactions that are occurring
at particular temperatures.
It's not so much about the time you cook your
meat at whatever temperature you're cooking
it, it's really the actual temperature of
the meat in itself AND what it comes up to.
So, when we take the piece of meat. Let's
say you take a steak tip and drop it into
a pan, you get something that looks kinda
like this.
Again, it's kinda hard to see in the projector.
Basically, there's this grainy adundant square
. I've done this. Where it's kind of, well
this particular example is basically rare
in the middle. Looks like medium-rare and
you have well-done out here and notice the
outsides brown from the Maillard reaction
we were talking about earlier.
So, one question to I get asked a lot at this
point here, well, why are we told always to
cook things at 165 degrees? I mean, if the
proteins in here are really ideal at 135,
140, like why is it we're constantly hammered
with this "Why 165" number? And the reason
for this is this.
Salmonella, another food-borne illness, definitely
not a fun thing to come down with. And one
of the main reasons we cook food is that it's
safe for us to eat. The standard rule is actually
given in food safety, this thing called the
danger zone. It basically says don't hold
food between 40 and 140 for more than two
to four hours.
It depends upon what state you’re in. The
laws of food safety are actually state by
state. But essentially in that time window,
in that temperature range, then you start
running into problems. Now, you'll notice
this nice, little square I have here is a
simple model of what's going on.
And there's a little dotted line, which is
actually a better model of what's really going
on, which is essentially that bacteria like
to multiply at different temperatures and
different rates. So it happens that salmonella
reproduce best at body temperature. And what
food safety people are concerned about is
the quantity of these pathogens that are present.
It's not really like your food is either safe
or unsafe, it's really a probability how unsafe
is it. And that's kind of, you know, a little
icky when you think about it at first, but
once you understand it's really about probability
and odds, you can start understanding how
to mitigate those risks and actually correctly
taking the [inaudible] and start doing some
fun things.
So, you don't have to just take my word for
it. In terms of things like cooking foods
below 140, you can actually do this. Even
according to the people that set these guidelines.
So the Food Safety and Inspection Services
has a table that says here's how long you're
supposed to cook food at various temperatures.
If you wanna cook your chicken at 136 degrees,
you can do that. You just have to hold it
at the temperature for over an hour to make
sure it's properly pasteurized. So, it's really
about reducing the quantity of pathogens that
are present to a sufficiently safe level,
such that it's not likely to hurt you.
Now, why would you wanna do this? Well, we
were talking about myosin and actin a few
minutes ago and it comes to this texture of
the proteins. If you can get something to
a point where it's safe to eat, but you haven't
denatured the actin, well, you're not gonna
say it's delicious, just safe.
And that's always the end goal. So, simple
model. Cook your meat to 165. And by meat,
it's really usually poultry. The better model
is really 140 degrees is OK as long as you
hold it correctly to pasteurize it. So, once
you do this, you can do fun things like this.
You'll see the piece of meat on the right
is basically medium-rare. The whole thing,
center to edge. You also notice the outside
has no brown crust on the outside 'cause it's
got no Maillard reaction. Any guesses as to
how I did this?
>>Audience Members: Sous vide.
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah. I asked this like, two
years ago and people would be like, "What?"
Yeah. This is called sous vide cooking. It's
a really simple concept. It basically says
hold your food in an environment that's at
the target temperature that you want to cook
something to.
So if you take a piece of meat and you're
wanting that steak to be at say, 140 degrees.
Instead of putting it into a 300 degree oven,
you can put in into an environment that's
140 degrees. And eventually, it'll go up to
a temperature of 140 degrees. It works great
for eggs. Hey. No worries. Are there any gingerbread
cookies left?
>>Female Helper: No, we don't have any here.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: So, it really comes down to
the sous vide stuff that it's really about
the temperature that you're trying to get
your material to. It can be your target temperature.
And the benefit of this is that you can't
overcook things because you're not talking
about an environment that's hotter.
So if you've got that actin protein in meat,
for example, it doesn't really begin to go
until 150. Well, if you put it in an environment
that's 140 it never gets to be 150. That reaction
never triggers. So, you can't overcook things.
Eggs are a great example. This is my set-up
at home.
This is called immersion recirculator. It's
basically a piece of fancy lab gear that keeps
water at a particular temperature and it's
got a little propeller that agitates it, more
on that in a little while. But the eggs themselves
work out really, really well this way. Think
about the temperatures that are involved in
egg.
You drop that egg in a regular cooking situation
into a pan of boiling water and it does this
and gets hotter and hotter, right? In like
five or seven minutes, then you basically
pull it out, somewhere right around here.
Right in the really, really narrow band that's
the ideal temperature range for eggs.
And hopefully, you timed it right. About 144
and 158 refer to the two temperature points
at which proteins in eggs begin to denature
and the upper limit where most of them actually
set. So a really good soft poached egg is
somewhere in-between that range.
And depending on how well you like your eggs
set, it's going to be somewhere between there.
There's 15, 16 different types of proteins
in these eggs and they all denature in that
range. This is the sort of thing where you
can have fun playing with it one degree at
a time just to see what your perfect egg is.
The thing about doing it with sous vide style
is that you set your temperature of your bath,
put your egg in, and the egg just ramps up
in temperature and finally just reaches that
ideal temperature point, but it never over
cooks. So you get this egg that is essentially
perfectly soft poached and just sits there
for a couple hours.
So, if you're trying to cook brunch for 30,
40 people, you just put the bucket out, put
your eggs in, set the temperature and walk
away and forget about it. And they won't ever
overcook. The key to making sure that--. The
one thing that I want you to really understand
to hammer home is that it's the temperature
that's important here.
Time is just a proxy for temperature. When
you put those cookies in your oven and you
time them for 12 minutes, well it's really
about how long does it take for that mass
of dough to come up to a certain temperature
at the temperature of your oven. But it's
really the temperature of the actual mass
that matters.
So here's a photograph of an egg that had
been cooked this way. It's kind of hard to
see, so here's a video of it. The other cool
thing I was doing things this way was this
one layer of egg on the outside that doesn't
actually set up until a higher temperature.
So the egg just falls out of the shell when
you do this. It was like, totally awesome.
[laughter]
And you'll see coming on the screen here in
a minute, you can see the texture. The yolk
and the white have almost the same texture.
They're both mayonnaise-like consistency when
cooked at a certain point.
There you go. Yeah, and they're delicious.
I mean like, if there's one thing you can
go home and try is sous vide eggs. Definitely
hands down. So this is a piece of gear that
I have. It's called an immersion recirculator
and it's expensive. Three, four years ago,
this was the only way of doing it, but there
are now better ways of doing this.
There a consumer device out called the Sous
Vide Supreme. They're like three or four hundred
dollars. If you've got counter space and the
cash, it's certainly very easy and they look
nice next to your other stainless steel appliances.
[laughter]
But if you're like me, a pair of wire cutters--.
This works. It works very well. Just say your
crock pot or any slow cooker, interpose on
the power supply. Rig up your own thermal
coupler and drop it in the thermostat controller
and you're good to go.
And it's actually easy. And I get questions
a lot of times about, "Well, there's no circulator.
There's nothing to agitate the water bowl."
For whatever reason it seems that, at least
for the stuff I've done in the slow cooker,
the heat source in the bottom over a large
enough area.
There's really no gradient inside the container.
You don't have to worry about it so much.
One other thing I neglected to mention earlier.
When you pulled that piece of meat out it
didn't have that brown outside. There was
no Maillard reaction on that. And that's one
of the really good key characteristics of
a really good steak.
So, what we do is after you take it out of
the sous vide environment, you then drop it
into a pan. You sear the outside. So you're
basically still getting that reaction outside,
but you've taken the two reactions, the external
temperature and the interior temperature,
and you basically are controlling for them
independently of each other.
If you don't have any kind of race the outside
temperature and the inside temperature. So
you were saying earlier you're always like,
overcooking the outside and the middle is
rare.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Yeah.
>>Jeff Potter: It sounds like you're barbecue
is too hot. So, try cooking it at a lower
temperature. That would be my guess. So, kind
of in summary. I mean, if there's a high-level
couple of bullet points you'll hopefully remember
tomorrow or next week, this is simple models,
simple predictions that will help you recover
when disaster strikes.
Better models, better predictions. And really,
for me a lot of it comes down to just being
curious in the kitchen. If you walk into the
kitchen and you're like, "Hey, how does this
actually work? What's going on here?" And
you're not sure. Well, do an experiment. I
mean it's really easy to gather data in your
kitchen.
And when you're talking about cookies and
you're not sure about the difference between
melted butter versus room temp or even fridge
temp butter when you're making your cookie
batch, just take two batches and do them side
by side and see what the difference is.
'Cause you're gonna learn a lot more about
what's going on in that process by actually
trying it. And you can sit there and have
lots of guesses, but until you actually try
something and see what comes out, well, you're
not gonna really be sure.
There's this great quote that I saw years
ago that really brings home for me a lot of
these things. "In theory, there's no difference
between theory and practice. In practice,
there is." The reason for this is there's
always a delta between what your theory predicts
and what really happens in your life.
The thing is with a better model, that delta
gets smaller and smaller. And so, there always
will be a difference, but hopefully by understanding
some of the science that difference will be
easier to understand even smaller. So with
that, I figured that it'd be much more fun
to open this up as a conversation and talk
about questions you guys might have.
Hopefully I've given you lots of ideas and
being aware of things to talk about. But I'm
totally happy to hang out for the next half
hour and answer questions and strategize a
little bit about questions you might have
and how to figure out answers about it. So
with that, thanks.
[applause]
Jeremy.
>>Male Presenter: You mentioned that people
preferred tastes as the proteins changed at
different temperatures. Is that evolutionary?
I mean, is that like, have there been studies
done to show that we like it tasting better
because it has less bacteria, therefore we
live longer, blah blah blah blah blah?
>>Jeff Potter: I don't think that that's been
done. And I don't know how you'd do that.
But textural preference of meat stuff is definitely
a personal preference based on what you grew
up with.
>>Male Presenter: OK.
>>Jeff Potter: So it's the reason why--. If
you look at older people, they tend to actually
prefer their meats cooked well done or well.
They don't like that medium rare texture.
A lot of it comes down to as we learn more
about food safety, we've relaxed the rules.
So actually just recently in the last few
months, it's now considered safe to cook your
pork to 145 as opposed to 165. That's because
trichinosis, which was a concern in pork originally,
it's basically not in our meat supply, at
least here in the US. It's just the same thing
with meat texture stuff where it's like, well,
two generations ago, people really cooked
it to make sure they weren't gonna get anything.
Now it's actually OK to go even colder. I
don't know about being able to show it biologically,
evolutionary. I think it's more cultural than
anything. Good question though. Thank you.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: Your salmonella
food safety graph, I noticed the dotted line
was still on zero below freezing.
>>Jeff Potter: Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: How far below freezing
does it have to go before it's actually zero?
>>Jeff Potter: Pretty gosh darn cold. For
things that deal with food safety, that dotted
line really isn't so much of a concern, but
spoiled bacteria, it is. This is why if you
put things in your fridge, they eventually
go bad.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: Right.
>>Jeff Potter: 'Cause they're, really it's
something multiplying at that temperature
range. I don't know below freezing at what
point it actually ceases to get, I think there
are some, but even at freezer temp it could
be an issue, which is why the guidelines say
not to hold food in your freezer for more
than six months.
I think there actually is some stuff that
can come up, but it's such a slow rate that
most people don't get into product limits.
That's a good question to look into more detail.
And the thing about that dotted line on the
high side is that really, the highest temperature
hits 130 a little more serious, the next highest
is at 122.
So, this is a cartoon line. Obviously, it's
not specific bacteria. But the thing is none
of these things really multiply above 131-ish.
So holding food at 140 is actually safer than
40. Think about it. So, 40, they can't actually
multiply. They can't get around. This rate
is so slow that it's not really an issue with
how to consume it.
But given the choice between eating beef stew
that's been held at 140 degrees for six weeks
versus held at 40 degrees for six weeks? I'd
take the 140 degree. 'Cause it basically,
at that point, it's clean, it's sterilized
it, how long it's there.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #8: In sous vide, though,
you're bringing it up to the temperature much
more slowly--
>>Jeff Potter: Right.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #8: which means it
spends more time in that bulge of this curve.
>>Jeff Potter: Yes. That's a really good question
which is this sous vide stuff where you drop
it in. And basically, you're dropping it in
from fridge temperature and it has to traverse
this entire span.
And it takes whatever length of time. This
journey is normally not a problem in sous
vide, because we normally portion the foods
to individual portion size, and so the actual
food comes up to temperature pretty quickly.
If you take like, let's make a number up,
like a six-ounce steak.
You drop it. And it's at 40 degrees. It's
gonna get up to temp pretty fast. If you took
five pounds of chuck roast that's been frozen,
like that's, like don't do that.
[laughter]
And the reason for that is that the center
of that is gonna be between that 40 and the
140 for such a length of time, that depending
on what your environment is, there's some
big huge variables in there that it's just
gonna sit too long in a bad temperature.
I should probably add a little asterisks here
and say things like steak or other meats that
are called WMULT, Whole Muscle Intact, the
center of these pieces of meat are actually
sterile. In those cases, you really only care
about the surface, 'cause we were at surface
contamination during butchering, slaughtering,
transport work into the kitchen.
So, this is why it's OK to do things like
take your steak, sear it outside and then
serve it rare. 'Cause even in the middle is
essentially, in a rare case, even let's say
120 degrees, obviously well below that safety
point. It's sterilized. 'Cause it hasn't actually
been contaminated.
So things like ground hamburger, though, where
ground hamburger is all outside, that there's
no inside. I've secretly wanted to go to a
food safety convention and like, serve hamburgers
and ask the people, "How do you want this
cooked, medium rare?"
'Cause like nobody should want their hamburger
cooked medium-rare because it's at a temperature
at which you haven't actually properly pasteurized
and many pathogens there might be present.
I will note that you can properly pasteurize
hamburgers to medium-rare using sous vide
cooking.
So, that's where having a better system of
models comes into play 'cause you can start
doing some fun stuff like not worry about
organisms that might be present. Go for it.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: You can presumably
get away with it if you knew the meat was
ground immediately before you cooked it, too.
>>Jeff Potter: Yes. If you have control over
the--. I mean, it also depends on what the
problem or the source of the contamination
is at that point. I mean, yeah. If you're
grinding it yourself, you've got lots of control
over everything.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: If you sear the
outside.
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah. If you sear the outside,
then you have a completely sterilized grinder,
it's called beef tartar. And they serve that
at restaurants.
[laughter]
I mean, as long as it's clean, you're fine
going in. But a lot of the food safety stuff,
it basically assumes the worst-case scenario.
Let's just assume this piece of poultry is
infected with salmonella to the worst possible
degree.
And then we need to reduce the log D, the
term is log D reduction. We need to do a seven-fold
reduction. Only one in a million are going
to survive after cooking that. Like, that's
the statement. That's the numbers they give
you. So I mean, their concern is safety, not
taste and texture.
That's where the balance always comes into
play. [pointing to audience member] In the
green shirt.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #10: Sir, on the topic
of sous vide taking a long time to come up
to temperature, has anyone in the sous vide
community looked at a trick that, I think,
hunters used a lot in time where you say,
"Oh, if I want some stuff that I dump in a
bath of hot water to be at a particular temperature,
I approximate the stuff by room temperature
water and make the water extra hot so that
when I dump it in, the temperature is, after
everything is said and done, is gonna be what
we want."
>>Jeff Potter: This is a good idea and I'm
sure it would help in theory.
[laughter]
In practice, when your container of water
is this big and the food you're putting in
is already at 40 and we wanna make it 140
and it's not actually a problem being a food
to temperature criteria.
The bigger problem that does come up with
sous vide stuff is once you get to temperature
the question is then what do you do with it?
So, if you're a restaurant and you're doing
something that you're gonna bring up to temperature
and you're gonna put it in the fridge.
And the next day, you're gonna take it and
heat it back up. You're now traversing that
span, like three times. And it's the cumulative
time that's the matter, unless you actually
properly sterilize it by the time you get
it up to temp, which isn't gonna happen in
this case.
So in that case, there's a whole set of guidelines
called HCAP. I can never remember. It's like
H-C-A-P, Hazardous Control and something Program.
Basically it says if you sous vide stuff,
there's two methods. There's one that's cook/serve
and the other one's called cook/chill.
With cook/chill, you basically need to cook
it and chill it as fast as possible. Like,
dump it into an ice bucket, or ice and a little
bit of water to get it down really quickly.
So, in those cases, you stop worrying about
the temperature stuff and playing with how
quickly you can move the temperature back
and forth.
But if you basically do what's called cook/serve,
where you cook it and you put it on a plate
and you ship it out. I mean, like sous vide
in restaurants is great. Because if somebody
orders a steak, you've got it in a plastic
bag and it's in your sous vide tub. It's gonna
need some marinade in the bag so it's gonna
taste good, too.
You pull it out. Slit the bag open. You sear
for 30 seconds on a side, drop it on a plate,
and ship it out. Like, you don't have to wait
for cooking because it's already cooked. So
cook/serve stuff is really easy to do at home.
Cook/chill stuff is, just make sure you get
a cold enough bowl. There's a really good
guide online. Douglas Baldwin has this sous
vide, a guide. You can just Google sous vide
Douglas Baldwin. You'll find it. Great page
that details like everything down to like,
I mean, he's done a fantastic job of coming
up with literature, of coming up with great
tables. So, that's where I point people to.
Gotcha.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: How does contamination
and danger zone and such vary with vegetables,
with non-meats?
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah. You're more likely to
get food-borne illness from your veggies that
you are from your meats at this point. It's
the number one metric. We don't cook lettuce.
If you think about all the salmonella outbreaks
that have happened, like spinach, than things
where you're not actually adding heat to it.
Wash your veggies. I mean, really. Wash your
veggies. I don't know if I answered your question.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: Even cooked vegetables,
like cooked vegetables you'd keep a whole
lot longer than cooked meats 'cause you don't
have, they're less likely to contaminate.
It that true, or no?
>>Jeff Potter: Umm.
Well, it's not just contamination. Things
like bacteria, and you need a bunch of different
variables to be able to survive. For bacteria,
[inaudible] they need something to munch on,
and veggies certainly have plenty of nutrients.
There's other things like acdity, pH, temperature,
time. I don't mean specifically a container
of veggies and a container meat in your fridge,
which is the way to go faster. I know that
my food is not a problem because I eat it
faster than the bacteria will. Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: But really probable,
it's just we're more aware of meat and temperature.
>>Jeff Potter: People are very afraid about
getting sick from meat that is not properly
cooked. They should be more worried about
getting sick from veggies that have not been
properly washed. I think that's a pretty safe
tip.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: Well, I now have
a follow-up to that question, which is do
you have any, is there any special procedure
for properly washing your vegetables?
>>Jeff Potter: Google it.
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: It ought to be
possible. So, turkey brining, which is a tradition
every Thanksgiving, it seems like it should
be possible to sous vide your turkey in the
brine.
>>Jeff Potter: Yep.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: Have you seen
people do that?
>>Jeff Potter: I've slow-cooked--. You actually
use a slow-cooker. So like, a turkey leg.
Oh, let's see. Long, rambling tangent. OK.
Actin, myosin, another important thing called
collagen. Meats that are really high in collagen
are things like duck legs, short ribs.
These kinds of meats, the collagen has to
be broken down, hydrolyzed, denatured and
that takes up a long time, which is why a
dish like duck confi , you have to cook it
for like, six to eight hours. And that temperature
of the collagen goes to 165, 180. It's a Maillard
reaction.
It's higher than those minor reactions, also.
If you take a turkey leg and put it in water,
throw a turn or two of salt in that, put it
in your slow cooker and turn it on for a day.
You'll come back a day later to an amazing
turkey leg that's perfectly brined and everything.
You don't need to throw that much salt in
there, enough salt that would actually inhibit
bacterial growth as far as I know. So, obviously
salt in water is, I mean, this is how you
can get things like lox or jerks or fish.
It's like basically taking the salinity to
a high enough level to where the bacteria
cell then literally ruptures and destroys
the cells.
I don't know if you could actually like, cook
a turkey in just salt. They have to be food
safe, like turkey jerky.
[laughter]
I'm sure it's doable. It just doesn’t sound
like something I would go and buy, but it
could work. Try it and let me know.
[laughter]
I'll get food poisoning.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: Not to [inaudible]
on food safety, but--
>>Jeff Potter: No.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: I'm curious
what we know about the science of what flavors
go together. So, I had a friend come over
at my house and looked at my not particularly
extensive spice rack and said "Do you actually
know how to use all of those?" and I said,
"Well, yes."
But when he asked like what, how do you know
what goes with what, I had no answer for him
whatsoever other than experience.
>>Jeff Potter: So it seems that chemical similarity
of compounds is predictive of how well the
flavors will go together. And there's a great
website called Food Pairings, where this guy
has done a whole bunch of chemical analysis.
And you give it an ingredient and it tells
you what's similar to it.
Somewhere in the book is a couple of screen
shots from it, in Chapter Three, on page number--.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: Well, I got
one, so.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: I'm trying to--. It's Food
Pairings. If you Google food pairings, you'll
find it. Here we go, it should be that. Page
143. So, you'll see the top of that are two
little diagrams. They look like that. So yeah.
Flavors that can go together seem to be based
on chemical similarity. The way that our noses
smell things--. Well, sense of taste and smell
are totally truly fascinating, 'cause like
there's so much that goes on. Taste is relatively
straight-forward. There's chemical receptors
on your tongue that are able to fire off for
like, five or six different types of categories
of compounds.
So, some things taste sweet, some things bitter,
sour, you know all these things. Maybe metallic
ions. There's still a question mark for human
tongues. They found receptors for that in
dog tongues. It’s probably quite reasonably
that some of us have those as well.
Smell is a lot more complicated. Your nose
has somewhere in the order of ten thousand
different receptors that key off different
aspects of a molecule. At least this is the
current theory. And any given molecule can
trigger a different number of receptors. So,
it's like the chord on a piano, where you
hear certain notes.
And so, the theory as far as I understand
it is that compounds that strike similar notes,
just like they would chord-wise in a symphony,
go well together, will likewise go well together
in food. So this is why things like, if you
look well, basil and tomato.
They go well together because they literally
have similar chemicals in similar chemical
families that strike the same receptors in
your nose. And likewise, this is why it's
hard to get things like chocolate and lobster
go well together. It's like they don't. Yeah.
It's like a C-Sharp chord along like a D-flat.
It's a dissonant. So, if you actually look
at some of the more interesting combinations
of ingredients that are done in some of the
high-end restaurants occasionally, a lot of
it comes out of actual just experience. And
a lot of top-end chefs will go and look at
food pairings and go, "Oh, we can do strawberry
with a few particular other ingredients and
it works." So yeah. I mean, go and try and
play with it.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: All right. Does
this mean I should go back and tell my friend
who had a challenge for generating free pair-wise
delicious combinations that do not go well
together to give up?
>>Jeff Potter: No. There are plenty of combinations.
But using this, you would probably come up
with a really good list of three pair-wise
combinations that don't work together. I remember--.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: Chicken and
basil and chicken and cinnamon are both [inaudible].
>>Jeff Potter: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #12: So, A and B
are good. B and C are good. C and A are good.
>>Jeff Potter: So, the guy that did these,
Bernard Lahousse, I remember him saying to
me at one point that I think you can bridge
like--. You can't like jump four or five jump
points. Like, they didn't work anymore.
I mean, he's a great guy. Like, I emailed
him to say, "I would love to figure out how
to come up with a combination of three-wise
pairs that don't work out chemically as a
joke on my friend." And then send me the list,
too.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #13: I was wondering,
you talked about safe heating. I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about safe
defrosting, or does that not even matter if
you're going to be cooking it afterwards anyway?
>>Jeff Potter: Safe defrosting basically amounts
to defrosting in this temperature range. There's
a line if you've got frozen ground turkey.
They say put it in your fridge overnight,
because below 40, above 32, it's going to
defrost.
But your multiplication of bacteria is slow
enough that you won't have any real concern
there.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #13: If you're trying
to defrost fish over like, an hour time period
for example, you don't have like a whole night
to put it in the fridge.
>>Male Audience Member: Put it in cold water.
>>Jeff Potter: Water conducts heat a lot faster
than air. So if you took that lump of frozen
fish and you put it on your counter at 60
degrees, you put it in a bath of water at
40 degrees in your fridge and you put a third
piece in your fridge, just in air.
The fish in water at 40 degrees is gonna defrost
fastest. This is actually why when we do sous
vide stuff, we do it in a water bath or a
liquid bath. You could technically do sous
vide in your oven if your oven went to those
temperatures. It's just gonna take 23 times
longer.
And because of that you run into too much
time in the danger zone. So like fish, I mean,
keep in mind about the danger window it's
like four hours. If you put it on your counter
to defrost in like two hours and you cook
it and you eat it an hour later, you're probably
fine. I mean, assuming you're starting with
a fish that isn't slathered with salmonella
or something.
[laughter]
But actually with fish, it's really parasites
that's the concern and freezing kills parasites,
so actually really, really good like high-end
tuna. Well, actually tuna [inaudible], but
like say salmon.
They're actually even frozen to kill parasites.
'Cause then you're not concerned about being
ill. Bacteria obviously don't die when you
freeze them. I mean, you store bacteria in
labs like, putting the samples in the freezer.
That's how you preserve them. Not so with
parasites.
So, the issue is shellfish and various parasites.
I mean, not that you usually leave fish on
the counter all day long, it would be kinda
gross, but yeah.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #14: What's the biggest
kitchen disaster you've ever had?
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #15: What was the question?
>>Jeff Potter: What was the biggest kitchen
disaster you've ever had? I think I've got
a slide of this somewhere.
[laughter]
There's one I don't want to talk about publically
yet, so let's just say it involves some TV
cameras.
[laughter]
I'm not gonna be able to find this very fast.
Let me see. Actually, it might be here.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #15: Are you looking
for your oven?
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #15: I found it. A
search for Jeff Potter high temperature pizza.
>>Jeff Potter: Man, you Google employees are
scary. It's like you have a plug right here.
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #15: I actually pre-searched
that last night.
>>Jeff Potter: Pre-cached it?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #15: Yeah, it's really
scary.
>>Jeff Potter: Where is it on my hard drive?
Here we go. Yes. Yeah, well. Sort of. Maybe.
I don't know if this is very useful. I will
show you a photograph and then talk about
it. So, here's the photograph. I'll wait for
the words "cleaning cycle" to pop in everyone's
devices.
[laughter]
Pizza. It turns out you can make really, really
good pizza if you're oven goes to about 900
degrees. And your oven goes to about 900 degrees,
actually hotter than that in the cleaning
cycle.
There's this guy down in Atlanta. This guy
named Jeff Varasano who first did this, maybe
a decade ago. He clipped the lock on his oven
doors so he could open it when it's on the
cleaning cycle. In the interest of readers
and research, I tried to replicate this at
home. Not that you should, but if you really
want me to.
It does make a pizza, though. So, that's an
infrared thermometer. Basically, it tells
you the temperature of things and it says
845 degrees. And there's a marked difference
between like 800 degrees and 600 degrees.
I put my hand in the oven at 600 degrees.
It's warm.
Like, 800 degrees is kind of like--. You almost
have an involuntary reaction to pull your
hand back. But the thing about doing pizza
in an oven this hot, is that it cooks like
in 45 seconds.
[laughter]
You drop it in. It goes [whomp], sets,and
you pull it out.
[laughter]
You also have about a two-second window between
undercooked and overcooked. But if you've
ever wondered how you get a really, really
thin crust pizza, it's cooking it in a really
hot environment.
So, if you go over to like, Harvard Square
where there's Cambridge One, they're cooking
on top of a charcoal wood grill. And I took
my infrared thermometer when they weren't
looking and put it in it. And it reads about
a thousand degrees. So, the difference between
the commercial pizza makers that are making
really delicious thin crust pizzas and you
at home is their oven is really hot.
That's why you can't really do it at home.
So here's the slide in question. One of these
is a surviving pane of glass from my oven
door. The other is a piece of Pyroceram 3,
which is quartz crystal. So the military used
it on missile nose cones in the 1950s. Thank
you Google. It's amazing what you can find
on the internet.
[laughter]
What's even more amazing to me was that it
was cheaper than the replacement piece of
plastic from the oven manufacturer.
[laughter]
And my oven now safely goes to a thousand
degrees. Since I'm renting my place out, I
have removed my lock to heat mechanism. Heck,
while I'm at it, I might as well show this
slide, too.
It has to do with negative 320 degrees. I
apologize that I did not bring my liquid nitrogen
here with me today. Because you can make really,
really delicious ice cream in about 30 seconds,
just like heating pizza in 30 seconds. Basically,
when you think about temperature--.
We were talking earlier about foods that temperature
matters. When you start dealing with extreme
temperatures, either really hot or really,
really cold, you can take that mass of food
to your target temperature and beyond really,
really fast.
[laughter]
The thing that's kind of cool about doing
it with liquid nitrogen is that there are
certain things like ethanol that don't freeze
under normal ice cream making conditions,
that do freeze at this temperature range.
So you can make ice cream that is literally
strong enough from one scoop to give you a
hangover.
[laughter]
And it's delicious. I highly recommend. This
is the part where you have to delete me saying
this.
[pause]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #16: To what extent
does the humidity of your oven matter?
>>Jeff Potter: It matters.
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #16: There's no control
part. You have to figure something out.
>>Jeff Potter: Well, yeah. I mean, that's
why bakers will oftentimes spritz or spray
water in their oven, or sometimes you'll see
a recipe that'll say "put a tray of water."
I mean, humidity is one of the big uncontrolled
variables in baking, especially.
It's something we just don't really deal with
'cause it's kinda hard to control for, at
least with tools we have today. Maybe in 20
or 30 years, our ovens will have a humidity
knob next to the temperature knob, which would
be really cool.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #17: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah, [inaudible] I mean it's
really an issue for dry cooking methods, any
time you're baking or roasting. 'Cause obviously
water can impart heat a lot faster. You got
more moisture in the environment. It's gonna
heat the outside of your food faster. So it
transfers heat better. So yeah, it matters.
I mean--.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #18: Because I was
thinking if you're cooking something for longer
there's the chance that it'll dry out.
>>Jeff Potter: Aluminum foil.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Potter: I'm pragmatic.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #18: OK.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #19: I know that
you can control certain points of humidity,
especially if you're baking, like melted butter
versus cold butter. If you use cold butter,
you're gonna leave stuff in the oven longer
because it takes a longer time for the fat
to melt in the batter.
>>Jeff Potter: Right.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #19: So then it melts
out and that's why you can leave it in even
longer. But it also takes longer for the cookies--.
If you're making cookies, it takes longer
for the cookies to spread as well. So, if
you use liquid fats they spread really fast.
That's why chocolate chip cookies tend to
flatten out really easily. But don't do it
from the refrigerator because then it takes
forever and then your cookies aren't as delicious.
They're too doughy in the middle.
>>Jeff Potter: Depends on what kind of cookies
you like. So much variability. You think you
have it perfect and someone's like, "No, I
like it crunchy." And someone's like, "No,
I like it chewy." Like, go look at the cookie
aisle at the grocery store and there's five
thousand different varieties of cookies because
people like the variation.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #19: Yeah, like there's
Toll House cookies that you can just break
apart. Sometimes they're not the best because
they just take too long to flatten out 'cause
they're cold.
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #19: You might have
to leave them at room temperature, but then
you have the bacteria problems with that.
>>Jeff Potter: Anything's that got sugar and
chocolate in it, sign me up.
[laughter]
You got a question?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #20: Uh, yeah, so perhaps
this is a foolish question, but let's see
if you have a good response to it.
>>Jeff Potter: Oh, no. Not that question.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #20: You've done a
lot of experimentation in the kitchen. Any
particular devices that you find really good
for trying new things?
>>Jeff Potter: Particular devices. I'm gonna
give you two different answers. One is kinda
generic. What do I think you should have if
you're gonna go and do experimentation in
your kitchen?
And the second's gonna be, what do I miss
in my kitchen now that I'm out in LA on a
temporary basis? If you're gonna go do experimentation
in your kitchen, just like any science, anything
that gathers good data. So, good scales, good
thermometers, timers. It's hard to find bad
timers. I mean, get one that tells you the
time.
[laughter]
So really, understanding the temperature of
the food, temperature of the environment,
how much weight-wise of particular stuff and
trying to control for it. That really comes
down to the really key aspects.
So I did this talk last December on the science
of chocolate chip cookies and as part of it,
we did an experiment where I had 500 people
bake batches of cookies, each of them being
an A B split at start up. Where it's like,
OK, one person's gonna make two batches--one
with whole wheat flour and one with regular
flour.
Or someone's gonna make it with melted butter
versus standard butter. And the reason I did
each person doing two batches was to actually
try to hold everything else constant on the
basis that if one person is making both of
these controls, there's gonna be variation
between kitchen to kitchen, variation between
chef to chef, variation between each batch
that one chef does.
So I wrote a very detailed protocol, writing
everything out to the gram. Like, this is
actually for a bunch of chemists down in New
York. It's like a bunch of chemists given
a protocol. This should be easy. The day of
the event comes up and a couple of people
had sheepishly come up to me and said, "I
followed your protocol, but when I looked
at the cookies they were all over the board."
I mean, I was trying to control for temperature,
for weight, for everything. We're talking
about a three-page, bullet point, single spaced
list that like, followed to the letter by
PhD chemists. And I couldn't get them to actually
within--.
So, even trying to control for time and temperature
and weight, everything else, there's still
so much variation that when you're trying
to do an experiment, really understanding
what variables you're capturing and recording
and you're actually not missing the bigger
variables, that's really the challenge.
As for the second bit, the second question
I said I'd answer, so I'm out in LA on a semi
temporary basis, enjoying the weather very
much. I will say I left here December 18th
and it started to snow December 19th.
[laughter]
I miss my immersion stick blender. And it's
kind of funny 'cause I have a confession to
make. I don't really have a kitchen in LA.
I have an electric hot plate, a toaster oven,
and a microwave.
And I'm like, "Hey. If I can't make this work,
yeah, OK. I gotta make this work." And it's
been fine. It's actually worked just--. I
didn't miss not having an oven or burners,
but I have missed my immersion blender, 'cause
it's the one thing that lets you pulverize
and change texture and make smoothies and
whatever, make soup.
There's so many things you can do with that
one tool. I haven't been able to make soup,
puree it, for six months. So yeah, I would
say that that's been a surprise for me, that
that particular tool actually. It's hard to
fake it with something else. You can't take
a knife and dice stuff up small enough. But
yeah. Any other question? I'm gonna go with--.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #21: OK.
>>Jeff Potter: Actually, I haven't gone that--.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #22: So, I guess my
question is there's this other device that's
a totally different way of cooking things.
It's like putting something in a temperature
bath, a microwave. So, what's cool about microwaves?
So anything?
>>Jeff Potter: Microwaves are kind of underappreciated.
I mean, they fundamentally work by vibrating
molecules [inaudible], so things like water
would get hot and inhibit microwaves, which
means that essentially they're only good for
wet cooking methods.
So you wanna steam some veggies, works great.
Take a container. Put some veggies in there,
maybe some asparagus, close the container
loosely, put a tablespoon or two of water
in the bottom and hit it with microwaves.
And it'll steam up and get hot enough and
your asparagus or whatever your veggies are
will cook.
Same thing like cakes. You can actually make
chocolate cake in the microwave under 30 seconds.
There's this whole theme here with 30 seconds.
What's going on? Pizza, ice cream and now
cakes.
[laughter]
You can make a cake in like 30 or 40 seconds.
Again, because a microwave's retain water
better when present with eggs and the batter
inside, causing it to vibrate, heat up inside.
That said, microwaves are not so useful for
things that involve Maillard or caramelization
reactions under normal circumstances. There
are probably some clever hacks involved with
bizarrely foiled, creased foil, like in popcorn
bags, which the industry managed to pull off.
So, that's why microwaves don't get the love
that maybe they deserved, because you can't
get those other reactions, the dry cooking
method reactions. But anything that involves
liquid, any kind of wet cooking method, seems
like a reasonable guess that you should be
able to do some form of cooking in the microwave.
Does that give you any inspiration? I don't
think I'd make pizza in one, but definitely
steam things, boil things. Potatoes work great
in microwaves, 'cause again it's about taking
moisture that's present from the potato and
get the starches to dissolve and set a. Do
you have a question?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #22: I was just gonna
ask if you had any tips for how the inventive,
intuitive, throw-everything-in-a-pan cooks
can describe how to cook to the precise I-need-a-recipe
cook?
>>Jeff Potter: Yes. Innovative and traditional,
write it down and take really good notes about
what you're doing.
[laughter]
OK, OK. Take two. Record you doing it, edit
it down, give it to them.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #22: YouTube!
>>Jeff Potter: Yeah. Absolutely. Have you
guys seen My Drunken Kitchen?
>>Male AUDIENCE MEMBER #23: Oh, love it.
>>Jeff Potter: It's great. Anyway, I'll hang
out and sign some books for a while and we're
probably out of time, so with that, thanks
for having me out.
[applause]